[Music]  an  estimated 250 million children  risk not meeting their developmental  potential  in the first five years of life  during this critical time strategic  interventions  can ensure children have a strong  foundation  to lead healthy productive lives  effectively we implement these  interventions  is critical to success early childhood  development  global strategies for implementation  is a course for those working around the  world  in early childhood development  programmes  we will review a diverse set of programs  that promote  early childhood development you will  learn why  some programs succeed while others do  less well  you will examine best practices in  policy  advocacy financing and pathways to scale  which allow you to reflect on what  changes you can make for your own  programme  we can ensure that we do not fail the  next generation of children  you